hi conan here welcome back to our show
we've been off the air for a couple of
weeks
and uh we're back now taping once again
in the iconic
largo theater in los angeles
uh i apologize still haven't cut my hair
uh down over my eyes not really quite
sure where i am right now
but it doesn't matter i'm with you and
that's the important thing
and we have a terrific show jason
sudeikis uh is here to talk about his
terrific new show
ted lasso so we'll be talking to him
in just a second now as i've said we're
here at the largo theater just a
skeleton crew
uh hardly anybody joining me here just
to keep things covid safe uh
now let's face it it's pretty much an
empty theater which can get lonely
and uh i don't know i'm not used to that
i'm used to a crowd
chanting we love you you're the best
tv icon whatever this is new to me
working in complete silence and then
check this out i was watching major
league baseball this past weekend
and i got an idea now you may have seen
this teams have been filling their
empty stands with cardboard cutouts of
fans check it out see that
when i heard that idea i thought that's
not going to work but it actually looks
pretty good
people are okay with it so i asked my
crew
to bring me whatever cardboard cutouts
they could find in storage at our warner
brothers studio just
random cardboard cutouts that were
hanging out in the props department
and guess what here's what they found
here's what we got
we got ruth bader ginsburg all right
we have conrad bain remember the dad
from different strokes
they found a life-size six foot six cut
out of former fbi director james comey
and for some reason they found four
count em four
kevin hart's that's my audience
right now and i feel pretty good about
it it actually looks like comey is
standing to object to some comedy i just
did
but that's not the point the point is i
need to fill the rest of the audience
and here's my idea i want to do it with
cutouts of my actual fans
i'm not kidding around this is real this
is your chance
to join my audience
in cardboard cutout form okay we're
going to make this happen here's what
you do
go to teamcoco.com cutouts
and upload a photo of yourself that's
right take a photo of yourself and then
upload it
be sure to include your name and city of
residence
and then we may put you right here in
our largo audience now in the photo
you can it's your choice you can be
enjoying the show
or if you choose you cannot be enjoying
the show
see if everyone in the audience if i
look over there and every single
person in the audience is enjoying the
show that's not going to feel realistic
to me
so once again here's what you do okay
you
upload a photo of yourself and you go to
com teamcoco.com cutouts
and you'll get all the details there on
how to do it and who knows
you may get to sit next to former fbi
director james comey
night after night you may get to sit in
between
two of the four kevin harts
anything can happen the sky's the limit
so let's make this happen and i'll give
you a shout out on television
see this quarantine isn't so bad
you